let me see how this matchup goes we're
going to go into the next match speaking
of
and let's see what character uh he goes
with
drum roll please he goes with [ __ ]
rom
smart pick i think smart pick
definitely uh uh one of those characters
that can overwhelm
uh your opponent and uh you know there
is no shortage of uh yoshimitsu players
that he's played against he's played
against
uh players like jumanji in the past very
talented yoshimitsu player as well
um amazing i'm pretty sure he's fought
amazing once or twice definitely fought
against mason before too
um i think that once again we see a lot
of different characters now especially
with like the the influx of online i
feel like i've seen a lot more
been a lot more readily coming across
some of these characters but once again
it could be the same thing that we saw
just recently in that match with you
know
fang and joy fury it could be a matchup
thing where you that
you know character matchup knowledge is
you know bleeding into this set and this
is important
because this is the finals for the king
of the hill let's see
uh jesse james was just in the stream
chat and he mentioned that this is a
great matchup for yoshimitsu so it'd be
interesting to see
uh if this is something that ukio knows
as far as you know the little tricks of
the trade that he can pull off against
certain holes that uh
bakaram has big damage on the wall
ouch oh
[ __ ] my one of those characters i
feel like you have to be versed in
dealing with you need to understand
how to fight focus i know a lot of
people like man this character hurts
but you there's still ways that you
can't kind of acknowledge is one of the
main parts of this matchup that you need
to pay attention to
knowledge is power steve not lose his
power the other half is violence mark
don't you ever forget it
oh yeah that's why he got the sword
equipped hands are out let's go
he's like you're right steve i need
another sword
oh here we go made you look
oh
it starts with the sword it ends with
the sword tied it up on rounds there
that's pretty
strong around there from ukiyo
oh here we go nice stuck
okay i thought we want to see a shorter
combo for the wall bin chain taking
and it's definitely adding up man james
was right right now it's looking really
good for ukiyo and yoshimitsu but the
big block
and the punish there from bing chang you
gotta be careful about the wall wow oh
my god
that was actually got like tries to duck
a little too early lightly
going away spins the rage drive spins
the blue stuff
the wall gonna mess up the combo i
thought it was still gets a bunch of
damage to flash
now he drops out to get up three oh my
god oh my gosh he had to deal with those
long kicks
bing chang started pumping the threes
man i'm telling you bro did you see my
man
spin out of the unblockable though yeah
he was ready he had something
cooking for that that was crazy but
unfortunate here we go
has the wall what's he gonna do for
mix-ups oh he picked them up hey that's
a big boy
that's a big boy big boy you gotta stop
tanking man
imagine if he was fighting brian right
now you would have ate so many times
that uppers
what's he gonna do here he is nice with
the lead but again he's in rage
oh my god
i can't say anything steve i don't know
what's gonna happen yeah erotica
ah looks like he doesn't care two rounds
a piece
final round first game oh man ukiyo is
really bringing the fight here
nice goes for the sweep keeping that
range game
big chang kind of a a bit more cautious
on the approach right now
he's he has something cooking [ __ ]
gonna have to be careful here
oh he's duck he's he's fuzzy quick
[ __ ] duck like that actually that's
really good that's one of the strategies
i employ versus uh
as well so i like that what are you
gonna do [ __ ] you're in trouble you
can't take anymore
he knows he's not checking oh he's fight
he still didn't take that up into the
ceiling fan
anyway he's too tall he's too tall he
got him into the ceiling fan anyway
oh that's why i'm feeling the drive is
coming
oh my god he tried to float over and he
still got hit that was o.d
oh my god to get over it that was so god
like
oh my god this second time is running oh
the downfall at once bro
did you see my man spin over
the rage drive low that was gone like
that was a pretty crazy match that was
just the first
first game bro that was garlic
he he's doing the freak nasty steve i
don't know what he's doing he's going
wild
oh man he's hitting the freak nick man
shout out to t-pain
man that was actually garlic
see we talked about like how movement
influences stuff right and i also talked
about being familiar with the matchup
i'ma tell you right now
him using the spin to get away from the
wall using the spin
to get away from the unblockable using
the float to get over the rage drive
that is yoshi knowledge right there that
is yoshi
knowledge right there it's very obvious
now that ukio has done his homework
against the character and he knows
the holes he's been doing fuzzy ducking
he's been doing evasive tactics to get
around certain things
and he's looking really strong but it's
all about you know putting it together
and making it happen
right the theory is there will he be
able to do it i feel like the more time
you give him the sharper he's gonna get
i think bing chang might i mean we saw
him play he started playing a bit more
cautious too in the matchup
so look first off uh my man half band uh
piskett
how was that god like he died bro did
you not see the evasive maneuvers from a
man with a sword did you not see him
float
man you sounded like a rookie you lucky
i'm commentating on how time you out
right now
but i'm gonna get back to these matches
look first off ben chang
is uh ben chang is looking like he's in
trouble right now i've already said that
he's been one of the toughest players in
the icfc
week in and week out and already has
matchup knowledge we saw the same thing
in the joey fury matchup
but it went the way of joey fury this
could be trouble will we see a character
switch no we're still getting the
[ __ ] rom
and i want to know what it's going to
change differently
oh boy oh boy here we go into the
matchup again
uh i i expended too much energy in that
in that last game so hopefully things
calm down a bit i
i really don't hope i wanted to be crazy
but i'm excited i am definitely excited
the knowledge here from ukiyo is really
starting to show through and shine
oh man shout out shout out to everybody
that's watching man thank you for
enjoying this nice sunday tekken with us
nice sunday tekken have a nice day it
was it's nice out here
and we're still looking at this tekken
because it's that good that's how good
it is that good sunday
good ass tekken let's go it's that
sunday fun day
let's go these guys getting into it it's
now 1-0
in favor of bing chang he's rocking that
[ __ ] ram and you know he's obviously
been doing work with many characters
throughout
uh these community series of events but
anyways we're going right back into it
oh we we have a change of costume here
from ukiyo as well he decided to put the
hands away
my man got the script on him man you see
the script bin chang i'm trying to beat
you that's what it says
yup he's pushing towards the wall gets
the crowd just attacked
and look at this big boy he's still
attacked anyway we saw some of the
setups that yukio had with yoshimitsu
old tries to hit a bunny is plus you got
to be careful tries to get the
unblockable once again
man yukio is playing very fast right now
oh yeah great
oh man he is on another level right now
what's he gonna do he should be able to
close it out
and now and now the the game is setting
in now right do i take on the wall do i
eat these hits on the wall
uh fakaram is definitely a big boy so i
feel like this is definitely going to
hurt him in some of these situations
oh and spacing wise oh that's a big
counter hit here for bing
and bing chang's definitely gonna get
the wall here
oh he misses
they're wearing this right now for yukio
bin chang with the jab this time didn't
get the balcony break goes for the lower
where the spin from last time
down four one stops the low
bench ain't getting a lot more active
with some of the strings knows that
yukio is going to try to move in between
him and down four one two to close out
the round only
one round a piece this is winner semis
again very very important here
because this is the winner semis the
winner of this will move on to the
winners final where they're going to be
able to play extended sets
so loser of this obviously going to the
loser side of the bracket oh that was
back to her big launch
hey tries to go for the unblockable
again gets the side oh my god the blue
stuff
any joke you don't want to win because
they don't want to win man that's what
happens you don't want to win sometimes
the heart is not in the battle right
sometimes your heart isn't in the battle
you drop the combo
and you don't want to win and you know
what bin chang is like you know what you
dropped this and i ain't gonna even tell
you about it i'm gonna put that in my
pocket
take that round and possibly the match
and he's gonna get the wall off this
combo
i mean is he gonna be able to come back
from this that that definitely knocked
the wind out of the
the match at least from the momentum
that uku had ukio now has another
opportunity to build things up
pushing towards the wall what what's the
oaky nice punish
he's doing straight be careful he's
doing it he might be dead
if you get this wall he's definitely
there oh
yeah uh-huh three rounds this time for
ben
chang and falconrom and the adjustments
are getting there the adjustments are
slowly being input
and now you see ben chang getting
playing it a lot slower i feel like too
and when um ben chang chooses to press
the offense
it's these strings that he feels like um
yoshi's gonna try to get away from right
he thought he was gonna try to get away
from it